if you're picking up in justice to
you'll have a few options I'm Tony and
this is your deluxe gamespot news update
the injustice to preorder page offers
three different versions of the game
standard digital deluxe and ultimate the
$80 digital deluxe edition includes 3
dlc characters a special shader pack and
a skin that turns Super Girl into power
girl complete with different voice
acting and dialogue the hundred-dollar
Ultimate Edition includes all of that
plus six additional DLC characters two
more skins and an extra shader there's
currently no word on who those extra
characters are or when they'll be
available injustice two launches for ps4
and xbox one on May sixteenth currently
the roster includes ten playable
characters 11 if you pre-order the game
and get access to Darkseid for more DC
heroes check out our gamespot universe
channel home of our video on the top 5
weirdest supermen and to keep up with
all the latest on injustice to hit that
subscribe button